alors ce weekend c'est la journée
internationale de la protection des
données on va voir si vous acceptez les
cookies donc là on va aller faire des
courses c'est quoi ça ça c'est la
recette des cookies Philips
original de jean-fançois pige Thomas et
jean-fançois
pigeaboration en collaboration avec mon
ami piège c'est parti pour la
[Musique]
liste à
gâteau bah ouais ouais là tu es pourquoi
la tu 80 farine pâtissière farine blé
sgle ah ben farine pâtissière c'est bien
alors ah bon j'en sais rien moi
bah il y a que ça ça ça par exemple
Jean-François Piège il dit pas mais tant
pis deux cuillères de levure chimique de
la levure chimique levure de boulanger
ouais ça doê ça ouais du beurre salé là
ok épice TR sucré ça doit être là c'est
là c'est là ah peut-être que là on peut
choper nos pépites de chocolat il dit
de 570 g de fève chocolat 60
%. waouh et par contre avec le chocolat
je pense qu'il faut pas rigoler bam les
trois
sucre poudre ici là sucre rou bien joué
Patrick c'est bon tu as toutes les
courses là là j'ai toutes mes
courses
bonne journée on décolle bon maintenant
qu'on a tout acheté la bicarbonate de
sou la levure la farine le sucre glace
le chocolat la vanille super cher le
beurre les œufs et le sucre alors c'est
parti tamiser les farines la levure et
le
sel je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
tamiser prendre Tamille m la farine
dedans et taper pour que soit juste tu
mélanges quoi sacré jean-fançois donc il
me faut 240 g
bon là je t'amise alors sais ce que j'ai
oublié non non mais là c'est rien que
pour ça que je peux pas être un
professionnel regarde ce qu'il y a dans
ma toque une souris
ouisou ah c'est
ratatouille bon là ça change là ça
change vraiment tout ça change tout ça
va mieux alors battre le beurre il parle
de temps en tempsouille ou pas non il me
fait des il me tire les cheveux et il me
fait des morsures ok battre le beurre
ouverture d' porte ouverture
grande merci deuxième truc que j'ai
oublié laver les
mains viser les viser les l'intérieur
des mains bien entendu je les fait avant
tout ah Jean-François il y a peut-être
des problèmes
d'hygiène 200
50 là Jean-François il me voit je suis
mort fait quel temps alors ce week ben
il faut il suffit de regarder la carte
ah mais je pense qu'il fait un peu
meilleur mais un peu frais quand même
attention n'oublions pas les faut pas me
poser trop de questions en même temps
bam ça fait tout seul il a dit 5 minutes
tuas un minuteur petit à petit le sucre
en poudre le sucre rou ajouter les œufs
un par un et mélanger j'ai deux œufs
incorporer la vanille j'ai la vanille OK
bonà je j'oserais pas dire que c'est
crémeux là c'est hyper sec là je vais me
permettre de balancer les au
là hop là d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien que
tu m'appelles chef là pour cette
séquence ok chef nickel incorporé la
vanille incorporé c'est au fur et à
mesure ou c'est
ouais moi ça me tend la cuisine en fait
je crois que je suis un peu stressé mais
gant François il préfère les fèves moi
je suis pas trop fè chocolat je suis
plus gros morceau un peu gourmand non
mais ça va être des énormes morceaux là
non ou là là
oh ouais la machine elle le
bloque ouais là c'est donc là tu attaqu
à la main c'est ça oui
oui
bam e bon ben voilà là on repose 24 à
36h ouais allez on passe à la C
la vage de main dans les interstice très
très important
TR alors on fait une
boule premier cookies c'est comm des
boules de neige plus de neige gr c'est
bon ça ouais je pense que c'est bon 12
minutes et c'est parti merde j'ai 12
minutes première
tournée
yes
yes du ça sent bon déjà un peu trop
B
super et merci Jean-François Piège merci
jean-fançois c'est super physique la
cuisine
en alors madame on a une question
essentielle bonjour madame bonjour
est-ce que vous acceptez les
cookiesz confection maison de tout à
l'heure ils sont encore chauds
normalement-ce que je goûte bah faites
comme vous voulez c'est votre
appartenance maintenant est-ce que vous
acceptez les Cookies Cookies ou vous
acceptez pas les cookies non merci OK et
sur Internet vous les acceptez ou pas ah
non c'est jamais non non plus j'ai pas
internet alors comme ça est-ce que vous
acceptez les cookies oui c'est vrai non
j'ai pas faim non franchement je prends
pas de su je suis désolé et sur Internet
vous acceptez ah oui sur internet non
pas tous pas tous ça dépend qui envoie
les cookies ouais est-ce que vous
acceptez les cookies allez pourquoi pas
ah ah ouais direct aucune
hésitation non ils sont encore chaud
ouais ouais du four ouis c'est bon
Jean-François Piège m'a aidé sur la
confection de ses cquies ah d'accord
connaissez oui quand même ouais et moi
vous me connaissez pas non non quand
même est-ce que sur Internet vous
acceptez les cookies ouais céit dire
vous voulez m'envoyer un message sur
Internet vous acceptez ah bah ouais je
dirais ouais je pense ouais B ok et vous
préférez les cookies d'Internet ou les
vrais cookies je sais pas est-ce qu'il y
a vraiment une différence je sais pas
ouis c'est vra bonne question je sais
pas ce weekend c'est la journée de la
protection des données et en fait on
demande aux gens s'ils acceptent les
cookies en général et bah vous acceptez
les cookies apparemment d'accord c'est
tout c'est tout bon on les a fait avec
Jean-François Piège ouais c'est la
recette de jean-fançois pige que vous
mangez là ok ça marche bon je connais
pas mais ok
c'est c'est un cuisinier
Conn d'acord ok ok ok je je
double bonjour on voulait savoir en fait
ce weekend c'est la journée mondiale de
la protection des données et je voulais
savoir est-ce que vous acceptez les
cookies sur internet en général oui
est-ce que dans la réalité vous acceptez
je ouais fait tout à l'heure c'est
gentil c'est fait maison ouais fait avec
jean-f pi c'est la recette de
jean-fançis piège exactement c'est trop
gentil ben je vais voir allez là peux
avoir un avis sur le cookie ou vous en
avez vous ici on peut
comparer ou vous voulez goûter nos
cookies ah bah pourquoi pas on va comp C
j'accepte les cookies d'en face un Cook
allez monsieur
cookies ça refuse les cookies merci
beaucoup on va tester vos Cook il y a
Jean-François pi chez
vous
pasre
partout très bon moins sucré mais c'est
très bien justement merci beaucoup merci
bonne
[Musique]
journée